So let me start this video by saying that
in case this code did not work for you,
ask us questions on the discussion forum. We are
here to help. Now, you may be curious about
this file called fresh_tomatoes, so let's talk about it
next. Now, I want you to recall that this
file, fresh_tomatoes.py, had a function inside it called, open_movies_page.
Now this function, receives a list of movies, and
then, creates and opens an HTML file or a
webpage that showcases those movies. By the way, it stores
this HTML file, in the exact same folder, as
all of your other movie program files. So let me
go to that folder now. And here is my
movies folder, with all of my Python movie files right
here. Notice that this is the HTML file that we
just created by running our program. This is the file
that actually showed us all of our movies and
played the trailer. And here is the fresh_tomatoes Python
file that you downloaded from our website. Let me
open it. Alright. Here is the code for our
Python file, fresh_tomatoes.py. Now, while I won't go through
this entire code in detail, I encourage you to
read through this program. I want you to understand
how it takes in a list of movies and
creates a website to show those movies. Now, we've added
comments to this file that will make this code readable. Alright
the next thing we want to do is we want you to
share the movie website that you've created thus far. So here's
your task, we want you to create your very own
movie website with your favorite movies. Once you've done that we
want you to share any one of the following two things
with us on the forum. You can take a screenshot or
an image of your movie website and share that with us on the
forum, or if you have access to a smartphone we want you to record
and share a YouTube video of you showing your movie website to a friend.
Once you've submitted your responses on the forum, make sure to check this box.